what's your age range for [ __ ] you  like would you [ __ ] a woman your own age  oh yeah I mean you do like women that  pay you to [ __ ] not so much that far for  everyone you know companionship no share  if that's the ultimate move ya know get  chicks to pay you got chicks oh dude  turn around we think about older women a  [ __ ] great Bush bro no [ __ ] I mean  have you seen these broads naked well I  will you [ __ ] them to help them I see  you women paying you two for  companionship well dude Wow  this how many women you got all I'd like  to get into another three but one of  them's killing me  what he means he always wants to [ __ ]  stick her tongue down my throat and  you're not into it  [ __ ] 80 gigolo your male gigolo might  be but you have a [ __ ] 80 year old I  mean if you had to I think it's my duty  you know right I mean you're good but  it's not a lot of stuff it's not like  it's not like it's like my fairy [ __ ]  town  No